[Music]
combat talk King yay we had July 19 the
city's hot yup the film record-breaking
heat and then this ring they're gonna
bring some record breaking he got Manny
Pacquiao on the left
your chief Thurman on the right now
Manny Pacquiao never really have had a
boxing name like you know like Iron Mike
Tyson
and um it's kind of weird now that he
has the fighting senator Keith Thurman
always had one time there was a time
when he was one time but let's check
this out this is an onion we're gonna
peel back the layers now I was going to
do like combat talk with I broke it up
between each fighter and then the fight
you understand but then I got to
thinking you guys are intelligent and
it's saying that I want you right now to
hit that like button turn on those
notifications like follow and subscribe
so you can get all this combat talk now
it's just the best fight that could be
made in a Walter weight division no it
is now let's get to the layers of this
fight right here now after being used up
by Bob Arum Pacquiao sign with
Mayweather promotions what he signed
with the PVC whose money is running the
PVC we all know how Heyman is the
mastermind but the financial backing
behind all of this stuff this Floyd
Mayweather jr. okay so understand Floyd
has a hand and all of this great PVC
fighting that we're getting Keith
Thurman went on a hiatus after shoulder
surgery
same thing with Manny Pacquiao remember
when he fought Floyd he got a shoulder
surgery now
his the difference between Tuesday
shoulder surgeries Manny Pacquiao got
his surgery done and was ready to get
back in the mix oh I'm gonna throw this
Keith Thurman took off more than a year
and a half we've got married who says he
was overseas and seemed very
disinterested and continuing to box big
names like Errol Spencer jr. was not
being called out and you have to see how
fight is look at their long term now in
this onion that we're about to get to
right now I'm going to give you the
physical aspects of each combatant we
all know that Manny Pacquiao is at an
accelerated age forty years old with 70
fights
- now Keith Thurman at 30 years old with
20-something fights think that where it
is a whole lot less but Keith Thurman
has fought the best and the wall to
weight division he's fought Dan Garcia
he's fought Shawn Porter he's for Robert
the ghost Marrero he's fought a lot of
the top walter wages to be the top Walt
away and don't get it twisted I'm not a
Keith Thurman fan I like one time but
when he was fighting fighters that I
plugged in he either lost to or he was
going to lose - I was going against
Manny Pacquiao we remember Manny
Pacquiao and dead whirling dervish
throwing punches like an octopus darting
across the ring moving from left to
right being the second best boxer in
this decade I'll fight him he's a
fighter
see you could say he probably is the
best fighter and Floyd is the best boxer
either way he comes in number two what
is the best of our generation probably
the best of all time de BES ever now
both of these guys had a long grueling
training camp both of these guys came in
at the exact same way one 46.5 do I
expect them both to be one 46.5 going
into the fight tonight
hell no do I expect Keith Thurman to
actually put back on that water weight
and come in at least 10 pounds heavier
yes I do
Manny Pacquiao probably come in 5 pounds
heavier now now that we talked about the
physicality up into the ring what's the
mindset of these two characters hmm do
you think Pacquiao still has the hunger
I think Pacquiao is still chasing that
giant pating that he caught from Floyd
that type of money is addictive
especially when you spend the money hand
over fist holding up a nation you see
your money head out of your pockets very
fast and when he's fighting with Bob
Arum Bob got most of that Mayweather
money so if he fights me whether now he
can get the majority of his cash so of
course he'll be chasing that check so
that puts you in a dangerous position
that means you have to fight a lot of
dangerous people let's not forget Manny
Pacquiao vs. Jeff horn see that's the
elephant in the room
the elephant in the room is Manny
Pacquiao vs. Jeff horn Jeff horn is not
the person back in the days that the
whole Manny Pacquiao jockstrap let alone
go 12 grueling rounds with him and take
his belt just wanna try that crap leg
blood CrossFit but beat the brakes off
that boy now that that isn't in
perspective now that you see where I'm
going now that you understand what I'm
talking about now let's look at Adrien
Broner versus Pacquiao and I thought you
would be served I thought this will be
the time that dead lady Floyd would
throw his hands but Pacquiao was all
over him like a cheap suit beating him
from pillar to post but I want you to
remember one thing about that fight
whose face look like they was in a fight
was an Adrian bonus
remember that 70 fights a ton of wars
not taking anything away from the man
but this is a young man's sport now I
want to keep Thurman Keith Thurman for
Shawn Porter for Danny Garcia he fought
the top welterweights in his division
and came out unscathed in final arrow
sprints
[Music]
now the reason why I believe that this
fight was taken even was because they
see a Horner ability and Keith Thurman
Keith Thurman mixes it up in his face
he can stand tall and he can box where
he consenting losses shots he goes to a
party he shoots that jab Keith Thurman
is probably the only Walter words that I
heard that I got oh and I'm ready to let
it go baby let's do it
and I guess him sign of fights has
definitely proved his words to be true
now let's get to the desire part who
really wants to spike the most this is
the fighting senator that's chasing down
at 100 to 200 million dollar fight would
Floyd again or is the young lion who's
willing to go through the fire to grab
this old man's Pelt and rock that belt
because he feels that if he knocks out
[ __ ] on in such a dramatic fashion that
he will get that mayweather fight see
Keith Thurman is at a point now where he
doesn't want to fight these young dogs
he doesn't want to fight a bud Crawford
he doesn't want to fight at Earl's
Sprint's he doesn't want to fight
let him charlo boys he wants to just get
some money get out go live life with his
new wife and if you can get some easy
pickings on the way food is good for him
that's why we've never really seen them
with that top top top dude
then I don't think it's for my lack of
trying
let's let's inspect one time let's
respect the guy with the old that's in
this fight now let's get into technique
in a ring and how this fight mixes up
Manny Pacquiao closes distance with his
feet not his hands what I've noticed is
that his hands and his feet is not
aligned now everybody labs keep thumbing
also jokes about it that says Manny
Pacquiao has t-rex arms but once he gets
inside he's letting his hands though
he's gonna be all over you like an
octopus when what I don't like about
Manny Pacquiao is when he steps back his
hands down and he's boxing bouncing from
side to side
this is Wicky thermicon landed jab in
the right hand
Manny Pacquiao doesn't take punches to
the head well actually punches to the
head on Manny Pacquiao is very
devastating he reacts bad to punches to
the head Keith Thurman reacts bad to
punches to the body
many Pacquiao's bread and butters
punches to the face
Keith darman's bread and butters punches
to the head in that equation you can see
where I'm going I don't think this ends
up the same way as Pacquiao vs. Broner
I believe this young line is coming to
feast I believe that this young lion
will let those hands go
I believe when worst comes the worst
keep them and throw that hand first do I
want to see one of the best of my
generation go out there and knock Keith
Thurman out do I think that fuels him
tell me he's seen a check for a hundred
million do you understand where check
four hundred million look like the type
of motivation is that you're with arms
reach every time you turn around he's
hugging ellaby Pacquiao is Elodie is
that ear shot away from Oh Mayweather
[Music]
you don't think Floyd want easy money
I don't think Floyd to come out to fight
Thurman but I think of Pacquiao beats
Thurman oh but this fight excuse me this
fight I think Thurman wins this fight
I think Thurman wins this fight in a
unanimous decision it's both for these
dudes having been knocking nobody out
let's keep it a buck let's keep that 112
Ron split decision Keith Thurman
in this fight I would love to be wrong
do you have any idea how wrong I would
love to be in this fight but I got
family common sense tells you you've
speed less wear and tear think about it
you're going to go buy a car and I don't
care if one is a Ferrari if you got
300,000 miles boy I'm not trying to do
that I might have to take that Corvette
only 20,000 miles on it keep them moving
it's combat talk of the King get you
guys later see you next time when I got
Earl's friend versus Shawn portal hey
that's a fight that I can't wait this
[Music]